you can't really fake motivation no
matter how motivated you feel if you
don't go and do the thing that wasn't
motivation and on the other side if you
don't feel motivated at all and yet you
do go and do the thing that is
motivation
bonjour friends welcome back to the show
it is episode 500 which is definitely a
number that i didn't think that we would
be getting to the last
few mo all of the last year and a half
has been insane but the last six months
has been particularly
ridiculous
so i wanted to say thank you to
everybody that supports the show and
supports me
it's an incredibly small operation it's
me and video guy dean and assistant ben
and then some people that we rely on to
do other stuff and that's pretty much it
and i think this year we'll maybe put
out somewhere in the region of
300 videos on youtube 150 episodes
and the support that we get from you
guys
and the encouragement and the
involvement in really smart discussions
is
it's phenomenal the messages that i get
gas me up more than any amount of plays
or
buttons and plaques from youtube ever
could
so yeah thank you uh today i'm going to
go through a selection of some of the
best lessons that i've picked up from
the last few years some of them are new
ones since the last time that i did one
of these and some of them are ones i
forgot about last time and i'm just
deciding to add in now some of them i've
learned from the show and others have
just been things that i've picked up
from listening to other bits or research
or just life in general uh if you are
signed up to the newsletter some of
these might be familiar and if you're
not signed up to the newsletter and you
like what we do here at modern wisdom go
to chriswilex.com books and you can sign
up get a free reading list with 100
books that i think that you would love
and you'll get signed up to the
newsletter as well
let's get into it
the first one this is actually a lesson
from jocko willink that isn't even out
yet so this is an exclusive uh because
this episode doesn't go out until next
week but this is discipline eats
motivation for breakfast so i was
listening to jocko on sam harris and sam
was talking about the fact that you
can't fake bravery as an emotion because
you can fake being angry or you can fake
being upset or whatever but
if you fake being brave when you're
terrified that is what bravery is doing
the thing in spite of terror literally
is bravery or courage and i
suggested to jocko that perhaps there's
something similar to do with motivation
that
people over complicate motivation
because they believe there's some sort
of optimal mental state that they're
supposed to be in when they feel like
they're going to do it or they want to
do it or whatever but you can't really
fake motivation no matter how motivated
you feel
if you don't go and do the thing
that wasn't motivation
and on the other side if you don't feel
motivated at all and yet you do go and
do the thing
that is motivation and jocko agreed and
he said that's why i prefer discipline
to motivation motivation is fleeting it
comes and goes discipline is always
there you don't need to want to go to
the gym or meditate or walk your dog and
have a difficult conversation with your
partner you simply need to do the thing
and by doing the thing you shortcut the
need for motivation entirely
i mean that's
almost everybody that i know
that is incredibly motivated or the
people would see as being motivated when
you actually look quite closely it's
probably not it's discipline
masquerading as motivation
and
motivation can come and you can use it
you've had the right mix of songs on the
morning or the right uh pharmacological
blend of caffeine and cbd or whatever
else it is that you use
that that's great like take advantage of
it if you want to get some extra wind in
your sails but the point is that what
you're relying on should be something
which is more
replicable that's more under your
control and motivation is super super
fleeting like choco says so
let's really love that discipline eats
motivation for breakfast and the fact is
that you can use it when it's there but
if it's not you don't need to worry
because you know that you've got
something to rely on and that's where
learning about discomfort leaning into
it becoming accustomed to doing things
even when you don't want to do them
helps so much because if you only do
things when you want to do them you're
going to put yourself at the mercy of
the world
next one
this is gwinderbogle who
i absolutely adore and if you don't
follow him on twitter you should go and
follow him because he's he's outstanding
his substance amazing as well
absurd ideological beliefs are shows of
fealty an absurd ideological belief is
actually a form of tribal signaling it
signals that one's ideology is more
important to them than reason itself
than truth sanity and reality to one's
allies this is an oath of unwavering
loyalty to one's enemies this is a
threat display it's not always about
what's true it's often about how does
this make me look to my tribal
compatriots and to my enemies so this is
one of the most interesting things
that's made me realize about how the
internet works and twitter that a lot of
the time people aren't saying a thing
because they believe in a thing it's
like wearing a badge of honor it's an
identifier to the rest of their group it
is a threat display to the people that
they don't agree with and the more
extreme and the more ridiculous some of
these beliefs are when you look at them
with a rational perspective you say how
could somebody believe this thing well
you're presuming that the reason that
they're saying that they believe it is
because they actually believe it if you
go one step removed and you think maybe
what they're doing is they're saying
this because they want everybody else to
realize that they believe it and such it
identifies them within a particular
in-group or out group
everything kind of changes it becomes a
lot more about signaling it becomes a
lot more about
just seeing what
the internet interprets your actions as
being or what another group interprets
your actions as being and it kind of
explains why people can hold such
ridiculous ideological beliefs simply
because it it's tribal signaling
next one this is uh zach tallander my
new roommate
you are training for the difficult so
this is
uh
kariakos grizzly who is if you don't
know i think he might be greek he is a
incredibly large
man that lifts very heavy things
and
has become kind of a super meme i guess
on the internet and what zack's talking
about here is
kariakos was once asked why he trains
and he trains incredibly heavy it's a
very unorthodox way of training
and he was asked why it is that he
trained so hard and he said that he was
training for the difficult
and zach
dragged this out a little bit and said
that he thinks creativity stems from
difficulty so if you search for
difficulty in life in the processes that
you're doing then the creativity will
find you and the thing that i really
resonated with was the difficult is
going to come
in life
no matter what it is that you're trying
to do no matter how optimized you've got
your day and your life the difficult is
going to arrive you want to be able to
greet it like an old friend you want to
invite it through the door and then lean
into it because you know that this is
exactly why you've been training you
don't want the difficult to come in and
for you to not be prepared it's the same
as the motivation versus discipline
thing you want to be able to have
something steadfast that you can rely on
and if you're training at a five and
life can sometimes come in at the 10
you're not going to be sufficiently
prepared now there's some stuff to do
with creativity in here about the fact
that
overclocking how hard it is that you
train allows you to see things that
other people don't see so zack uses this
example of um jack
white from the white stripes might be
getting this wrong but
this guy who is a keyboardist singer and
guitarist
he
often makes his sets more difficult than
he needs to when he's on stage so he
doesn't have guitar picks on his mic
stand he actually has to run to the back
of the stage to get them and pick them
up he doesn't have his different
instruments nearby he has to sprint
around the stage he has other
restrictions that he places on himself
when he's writing songs so when he's try
i don't think he allows himself to get
new guitar strings and stuff like that
the reason being that the increase in
difficulty forces him to have an extra
degree of creativity it allows him to
see things other people don't see
because the stimulus that's coming in is
another one here's something that i
didn't write down actually that relates
to this and it's a jack butcher one this
is so important
jack is a guy that created visualized
value so if you've ever seen those white
on black images that are kind of
everywhere on the internet at the moment
naval tends to share them a lot and it's
a sort of a geometric pattern and a
particular type of font and i asked him
about
where his creativity comes from and he
gave this really interesting answer he's
a graphic designer by trade his
background is in graphic design
so you would think you'd be very seduced
by
fonts and colors and making things look
pretty and what he ended up doing
was constraining all of the things that
he usually would rely on as a graphic
designer so it was one color white on
black it was one font that he'd pre-desi
decided it was one particular type of
drawing style this sort of geometric
pattern it looks like space invaders
from the 80s
and the reason that he did that was that
by constraining the
degrees of freedom that he has
in certain areas of creativity that he
decided in advance didn't make a
difference
what it forced him to do was get his
creativity
really dialed in and maximized in the
area that he thought did make a
difference so that was his messaging how
insightful is the visual representation
of the quote that i'm talking about how
well can i display something what's my
selection of the concepts that i'm going
to put out there how good is that um
that to me
is such a useful
way to it's like an essentialist's
mindset when it comes to content
creation or really doing anything that
you're producing
what where can i restrict the degrees of
freedom so that i don't need to make
this decision again
and where can i
focus on the highest point of
contribution that is actually going to
make the difference so for us with the
channel we have a one color for the font
we have one color for the clips we have
one font style that we use we have one
layout that we particularly use there's
a reduced number of degrees of freedom
which allows us to focus on the stuff
that matters what does it look like what
does it say what's the titling what's
the design what's the image that we go
for and
it just makes things easier and also
obviously downstream from this you end
up with kind of a signature style which
is pretty cool you know having branding
branding that looks like
something recognizable is pretty
important and that's super easy to do by
restricting the degrees of freedom and
then allows you to have more bandwidth
to be able to focus on the stuff which
genuinely makes a difference all right
next up achieving happiness through
success is self-defeating so this is a
alex homozy tweet that he came up with
originally and then i repurposed it into
something that i've been thinking about
for ages if you haven't checked out
alex's stuff i highly recommend you go
and follow him on instagram he's
phenomenal he's super smart insightful
guy it's also an episode that we did
with him which you can watch somewhere
up here so one of the most common
tensions that i talk about and i see is
this
balance that people have between a
desire for success and a desire to feel
like we're enough so success is is
strange because presumably we want
success because we think that a more
successful life will bring us more
happiness and more meaning and more
fulfillment
but the problem is that we sacrifice the
thing that we want which is happiness
for the thing which is supposed to get
it
success we sacrifice the thing we want
happiness for the thing which is
supposed to get it which is success
so failure can make you miserable but i
don't know that success can make you
happy and high performers often have
this dynamic where there as a young
child their parents want them to do well
so they encourage their child to do well
by praising them when they succeed and
then criticizing them when they fail and
then what the child learns is that
praise and admiration is contingent on
succeeding so
the as they go into an adult this lesson
turns into i am only worthy of love and
acceptance and belonging if i succeed
and they're prepared to outwork and out
hustle and out grind pretty much
everybody else because they're driven
not just toward a life that they want
but they're running away from a life
that they fear and success and progress
it dissolves ameliorates those feelings
of insufficiency that they have so
success and progress have been
prioritized above everything else and i
i don't deny that a lot of high
performers probably do love the work
that they do and a lot of them will be
driven by this well-balanced and
simple desire to maximize their time on
this planet
but if i was to place a bet
i think that the majority of high
performers are
driven by fears of insufficiency rather
than a holistic desire to be better and
i think that people that are high
achievers on average are more miserable
than the average person so
what does it mean that the people we
most admire are the ones with the least
desirable internal states
if the pursuit of success is in an
effort to make us happy
and in the pursuit of success we make
ourselves miserable
why not just shortcut the entire process
and be happy
is that i don't know if that's possible
because
external accolades they genuinely
actually count for a lot they we need to
have some degree of external material
success that makes us feel validated and
respected and satiate our desire for
status and stuff
but i don't think that external success
will fill an internal void so this is
the insufficiency adaptation that i've
bro scienced so if your drive comes from
a fear of insufficiency and you continue
to disprove those fears with success in
the real world and yet the feeling of
insufficiency persists what makes you
think that the answer to this problem is
more success
there's no
clean answer here obviously the world is
messy and we're hopelessly irrational
but you don't need to let go of all
success goals you do need to spend some
time working out whether there's a
shorter route to the life that you want
by removing obstacles rather than just
pressing harder on the accelerator so i
mean that quote i can't remember what it
was originally about it might have been
to do with money i think
but we sacrifice the thing we want for
the thing which is supposed to get it
happiness for success i really really
like that like
if you're hoping that your success is
going to make you happy and in the
pursuit of your success you make your
life miserable
what are we doing here you know
next one where are we
uh out groups are more popular than in
groups so this is from scott alexander
the oldest pattern in human history is
here's a problem and here's a bunch of
people who are different than us let's
blame it on them so
i think it was around about the 2012 um
us election
they were looking at the voting habits
of democrats and republicans and up
until about 2012 when they surveyed them
what they found out was that democrats
preferred their party to the
conservative party and the reverse was
true as well but in 2012 there was a
flip and people hated the other party
more than they loved their own so you
could see a lot of the votes that have
occurred
since then as kind of protest votes it's
you
it's you voting not for an other
not you voting for a same or or it's you
not voting for an out group not you
voting for an in-group
and that
is kind of dangerous and it's also one
of the ways that you can quite easily
spot charlatans on the internet or
grifters or people who are
disingenuous uh or at the very least are
weaponizing particular types of dynamics
to
encourage you to behave in a way that
you might not actually want to if all of
the time what you're hearing from
someone online i mean this is almost all
of the internet at the moment is someone
pointing a finger at another group of
people and saying
they're the problem this is why we need
to stick together so that they don't
take over
hang on
how fragile is it that the reason that
your in-group is bound together is over
the mutual hatred or distaste of an out
group
that doesn't work that's not going to
work very long it's simply too fragile
right it's going to fracture and break
apart because all it takes is one person
within the in-group to identify another
person who's on the edge of the in-group
to now be the next out-group and they're
going to get shaved off and then the
next person's going to get shaved off
this is the the purity spiral it's kind
of the ridiculousness i guess of the uh
um intersectional uh ideology that i
mean we did this video not long ago
about um white gay privilege that being
gay if you're white
is no longer enough to be a part of an
oppressed class that you actually need
to have multiple intersecting
uh
grievances right
but the same thing happens on the other
side as well like you can see this on
the right that people point at a group
of people like these are the people that
are coming to take over the whatever
and
that should give everybody pause
do i agree with this person or do i have
a sense of affinity with this creator
this rhetoric this ideology this group
this movement whatever
because i genuinely care about them or
is it because my fear my innate tribal
fear of the out group has been
weaponized and i've been limbically
hijacked so that i'm now focused on them
that's
a very interesting dynamic and that
scott alexander thing is bang on the
money uh next one productivity obsession
is immortality by a different name
this is oliver berkman who wrote 4 000
weeks fantastic book if you're into
productivity but have kind of
transcended the
um autistic side of it and are now
moving into a more holistic view of
productivity this is fantastic this
quote is the drive to become more
efficient to all costs usually has
consciously or otherwise some kind of
fantasy endpoint where you're able to do
everything
everything that you could think of
everything that people could demand of
you everything you feel obliged to do
you could do it that's really just
eternal life by another means one option
is to live forever another option is to
do an unlimited amount in the time
you've got they both amount to a
superhuman approach that's oliver
berkman from
4000 weeks
i really like this idea the fact that
a lot of the people who
like me
get seduced by the idea of productivity
are doing it because
they feel like getting more done in less
time is going to give them a greater
sense of satisfaction
and there is no end point that they've
actually defined when enough is enough
the same thing happens with money right
going back to whole mosey's uh tweet
earlier on
the same thing happens with money people
don't give themselves a
set
amount that they're going to be happy at
when they're able to do it and
productivity can be the same it's like
look how how much work do you want to
get out per week
is it this many hours is it this many
uh studies is it this many podcasts is
it this many videos is it this many
whatever
and what happens if you're able to you
manage to ratchet and dial in your
productivity system until you're happy
to do that
what happens then well for the most part
what you do is you go well look at all
of this opportunity that i've opened up
now i can fill it with some more work
and you go right okay
that is an a never-ending way it's a
treadmill that you're going to stay on
and it is a way that you will continue
to fill all of your spare time
until you can't feel it anymore which
will be when you're dead
so i think a big
insight here is you need to set yourself
a goal of
what would a productivity endpoint look
like the same thing is really smart to
do for money morgan housel says the
number one first goal that you need to
make sure of when you're setting
yourself financial targets is to stop
the goal posts from moving every time
that you earn a little bit more money
you move the goal posts further away
from you and then want to earn more
money that is a never-ending chase to
continue to just acquire more stuff work
harder do whatever and this doesn't
matter whether you want to do your work
or not the goal of life should be to
maximize your freedom to do the things
that you want all the time the number
one advantage that you have with
productivity when you combine that with
financial freedom is that you can wake
up on a morning and say i can do
whatever i want to do today and if there
are some things i don't necessarily
fully want to do i can get them done in
a small amount of time so they impact my
day
uh in a minor way
there's another element of this that uh
douglas murray fell in love with
productivity dysmorphia so this is anna
codri errado and she came up with this
idea which is
the same way of body dysmorphia
productivity dysmorphia
doesn't allow us
to see the fruits of our labor on a
daily basis so
you spend all day working and you're
pretty productive maybe you get
distracted maybe you don't but whatever
you've spent the whole day working and
you get to the end of the day and you
look back and you feel like you've done
nothing you can't remember what you did
you're very disappointed with your
successes and your failures and whatever
it is that you achieved
and you're uh driven the next day to go
and do even more and it's just a cool
way of looking at the fact that we have
this
warped view
of
what we do
on a daily basis especially people that
are knowledge workers you look back at
the day and you don't have a bucket of
widgets right this is the stuff that was
to do this is what's being done and this
is the stuff that was done
it's not like
when your dad was a mechanical engineer
and he was cranking stuff right he could
show you a car at the end of the day
like you very well could have worked all
day on your emails and gone to bed with
more unread emails than when you woke up
that that's not typically the way that
work is to be done and yet productivity
dysmorphia
all of this combines together to give us
a very um
misaligned view of what we've done on a
daily basis so productivity obsession is
immortality by a different name pick
yourself an end goal in terms of what
you would like to be able to achieve
from your productivity system and then
productivity dysmorphia just make sure
that you're trying to be as rational as
possible when it comes to actually
choosing
what you're doing
and reflecting on the amount of work
that you've achieved in a day
next one
you cannot control the mind with the
mind so this was the first question i
asked andrew huberman and it's
the
essence i think of his work
pretty much until
he came around i'd always thought that
issues that i had
internally emotional states
um
lack of ability to focus
lack of ability to sleep to rest
to switch off to switch on
all of that
um was something that i kind of needed
to
i don't know like clench my mind around
you know before you're going to do a big
lift and
doing that uh and
he highlights the fact that the vast
majority of the reasons that your mind
is acting the way that it is is because
of an external stimulus or at least
something that you've done in the body
so
it just reminded me that look if my mind
is a little bit messy if my thoughts are
muddled if my sleep isn't too good
rather than trying to think my way out
of the problem i should probably just go
back to am i eating right sleeping right
getting enough water training getting
sunlight exposure okay then
what are the things i'm eating what's my
supplementation look like like have i
spent enough time with friends
all of that stuff none of this really
involves trying to think your way out of
the problem you cannot control the mind
with the mind you have to control it
with the body
it's so much more empowering right
because
all of our internal processes are pretty
opaque to us even the best meditators in
the world
they can't see their own minds they have
a clearer window into them but this
you go to the gym you lift some weight
you know that you've done it there's
nothing anywhere near as concrete when
it comes to the mental processes that
you've got going on so yeah you cannot
control the mind with the mind great one
next up fame ain't what it used to be
this is
a blog post that i talk about all the
time from kyle eschenroder and it's
called what do you want to want
this insight is probably my favorite one
from the lot and he said do you want to
be someone or do something the two
aren't mutually exclusive of course but
they're a lot less cohesive than you
might think fame ain't what it used to
be traditionally people became famous
because they achieved something great
maybe even heroic because fame was such
a powerful signal we all started wanting
it who wouldn't but this was the
downfall of fame people stopped wanting
to do something and started wanting to
be someone regardless of why
the goal is not to deserve fame just to
be famous the goal is not to deserve
fame just to be famous
once upon a time fame was bestowed on
those who earned it such as the heroic
general who risked his life in battle or
the famous doctor who restored sight to
the poor and afflicted it was heroic
deeds that made one famous today
fame is only granted to those who seek
it that's from the new philosopher
magazine so
fame
was it's been separated
from what it was supposed to indicate it
it used to be a trustworthy signal of
honor
or courage or creativity or hard work
or anything else
why is it that we chase it now so much
more it's because modern fame is the
promise of obligation-free status right
it gives you the opportunity to take
advantage of all of the brilliant things
of fame
without any of the hard bits of having
to earn the right to be famous
if you could shortcut the work bit
and just get the reward bit then why
wouldn't you and
obviously this gets fed into by the
um rapid ascension that we see of people
becoming famous like if if you can be
famous for drinking juice
while skateboarding down the street on
tick tock or being picked out of
obscurity to go into reality tv why
wouldn't you try and game that system
you know why why wouldn't you look at
someone it's kind of like a lottery or
the hunger games
it's pretty much like that
if you
if you don't
like the idea of working hard at doing
something or even not that you don't
like the idea it's simply that you see
other people who have been given this
obligation free status why wouldn't you
lean into it well hang on he didn't work
for his fame
i believe that i work harder than him so
maybe i can get some of that free fame
and i'll dial my work back as well and
one of the reasons why this is so
dangerous is because
when someone becomes inflated with fame
everybody else
has it in our power to deflate him
other people's heads are a wretched
place to become the home of a man's true
happiness that's arthur schopenhauer and
basically to become famous is to
volunteer to be a scapegoat because
you're gonna be treated like a king
until you screw up or people get tired
of you and then you're sacrificed at the
altar you give the public someone to
hate
all together and when you put this kind
of power into the hands of people around
us
our entire sense of self becomes an
abstraction right we have to check
twitter engagement in order to measure
our self-worth
instead of the action that we took
like abstracting what how you feel about
yourself and putting it in the head the
hands of other people
just generally that's a bad idea
roll it forward into a modern era with
social media and tribal signaling and
shows of fealty and absurd ideological
beliefs like windows
mentioned earlier on that
it is such a risky position to be in
you're checking twitter engagement to
measure self-worth instead of the action
that you took
this has always been my problem with uh
or one of the reasons why i think that
bodybuilding shows are so
you have to have such a particular type
of mindset to be able to go into that
competition and come out of it feeling
healthy because
your entire success within that is an
abstraction right you could objectively
be
bigger leaner
with more conditioning and better
proportions or whatever than the person
stood next to you but it's so subjective
the success criteria for winning a
bodybuilding show is so subjective it's
not powerlifting that's 300 kilos can
you pick it up yes
did he no right you win
it's nowhere near as cut and dry and
that's one of the reasons because
bodybuilding is kind of like a microcosm
of what we're talking about here
our sense of self-worth is abstracted
into other people's heads and then we
measure our sense of self-worth by
checking their reaction not by looking
at the actions that we took
and again like i said before like
fame can make you happy
if what brought you fame also brings you
happiness
what that means is that if the fame were
to diminish
you would still be happy
a lot of the time people are doing
things that they're only happy to do as
long as they continue to receive fame
for it so a great question to ask
yourself here if you're
considering a a career that you think
might be
born a little bit out of status is look
if i got zero status for this if i got
absolutely no fame would i continue to
do it i mean that's a pretty good
marker that the thing that you're doing
is internally generated and not
something that you need to worry about
uh but there's a quote from john boyd
that is this fighter pilot super
disagreeable fighter pilot who used to
have uh he was in the um
50s 60s 70s like the golden era of
fighter pilot and he used to uh put
cigars out on his superior ties like
this like crazy real
angry swearing american dude and he says
to be somebody or to do something in
life there is often a roll call that's
when you will have to make a decision to
be or to do which way will you go it's
the same thing again like do you want to
be somebody or do you want to do
something and
that's not to say that by doing
something you can't be somebody but
being somebody without having done
anything
that the that's the reason that people
have a particular sense of distaste for
like dynasty wealth and trust fund kids
we don't there is something
in especially in a meritocracy
inherently uncomfortable about people
that do that so yeah do you want to be
somebody or do you want to do something
next one the negativity bias is no
longer serving us so this is roy
baumeister who was on the show a couple
of weeks ago and this had nothing to do
with anything that we spoke about which
was the social psychology of sexual
interactions this is from a different
book of his he said life has to win
every day
death only has to win once
so the negativity bias which you may be
familiar with is the fact that bad
things seem to affect us more than good
things right so you can get 100
compliments and one criticism and you
will happen to remember the one
criticism more than the compliments
unless you've done a ton of mindfulness
when emotions of equal intensity occur
things of a more negative nature have a
greater effect on our psychological
state than neutral or positive things
something very positive will generally
have less of an impact on a person's
behavior and cognition than something
equally emotional but negative and the
best example of this that i got was
michael mallis told me about this he's a
fan of margaret thatcher and has been
doing a ton of research about her era
recently
he told me about the brighton hotel
bombing which happened on october 12th
1984. margaret thatcher and her cabinet
ministers were targeted by the ira at a
con conservative party conference a long
long-delayed time bomb was planted in
the hotel by patrick mcgee before the
prime minister thatcher and her cabinet
arrived at the hotel although thatcher
narrowly escaped the blast five people
were killed including a conservative
member of parliament and 31 were injured
after the event the ira released a
statement mrs thatcher will now really
realize that britain cannot occupy our
country and torture our prisoners and
shoot our people in their own streets
and get away with it today we were
unlucky but remember we only have to be
lucky once
you will have to be lucky always
today we were unlucky but remember we
only have to be lucky once you will have
to be lucky always and this is the
fundamental
asymmetry right of all anxiety the
reason that we
fear change and new things because
yeah sure the the new thing might make
life a bit better which would be good
but it also might make us a lot more
dead which would be very bad
that quote and that
we we only have to get lucky once you
have to be lucky every day is
fantastic and
given the fact that we're finite
creatures surrounded by infinite
complexity the fears and worries and
concerns that we have while painful and
completely illogical
are there for a reason
but the problem is that the reason is a
few million years old human existence
has never been as safe as it is now so
whatever problem it is that you're
facing
it's probably not going to be an issue
and that you're going to deal with that
issue even if it happens
you're here you're listening to this
right now what does that say it suggests
that all of the challenges and the
neuroses and the problems and the
overthinking and the sleepless nights
and all that stuff
kind of didn't make much of a difference
because whatever it is that you came up
against you dealt with it now you could
say well maybe all of the overthinking
and neuroses contributed to me getting
through the thing and without that i
wouldn't have been able to do it like
what are we talking about here like the
lions are not at the door when you need
to have an awkward conversation with
your boss tomorrow the
response that we have internally
to a lot of the things that we deal with
is completely disproportionate to the
impact of the thing that we're concerned
about and that's what this story and
the sequence of things the fact that uh
life has to win every day death only has
to win once well
death's pretty hard to find now in the
first world death is really really
difficult you know we've nerfed society
the entire world is created in a
desperate attempt for death to be as far
away from us as possible
and yet we respond to stressful
situations with that
mortal fear
it's not needed right
you've got here whatever it is that
you've gone through
it's been okay
therefore you should have at least a
good amount of faith that whatever comes
up against you in the future you should
also be okay with
uh where are we next what got you here
won't get you there so this is something
i've reflected on a bit more
since the show's grown and it's to do
with
where i spend my time and
a little bit of
brushing up against having a puritan
work ethic so i like to work hard and i
always considered that working harder
and doing more it's like quite a british
thing i think
is the solution and
one of the problems that you realize is
that
another hormozy quote he says um
beginners overvalue thinking and
undervalued doing
advanced people do the opposite
beginners over value thinking and
undervalue doing advanced people do the
opposite
reason for that is that when you first
start out with something for the most
part you're doing all of it right your
hr your marketing your
mother your
cook your cleaner your all of those
things and then over time what happens
is you your lifestyle starts to change
and
maybe becomes a little bit more
comfortable or perhaps the business or
the project or the family or whatever it
is that you're doing grows and that
permits you to be able to start thinking
about different things
and yet because you've ingrained this
particular style of work where you're
completely obsessive and overworking and
all of that
you try to map a previously useful mode
into this new position that you're in
but what you don't realize is that's
causing you to bounce off the limiter
right there's only so many hours in the
day if you decide that you're going to
do absolutely everything by hand you're
not going to delegate control you're not
going to relinquish anything you're not
going to have faith in other people that
they can get the job or the babysitting
or the cooking or the cleaning or
whatever done
if you don't do that
you are limiting your ability to
ascend to the next level and
what got you here won't get you there
is
me reminding myself that
the strategies that made me successful
or
gave me any particular type of advantage
in the first place aren't necessarily
the ones that i need to hold on to the
principles behind them
of maybe being detail-oriented or
perhaps being prepared to do the work or
understanding the fundamentals of
whatever industry or lifestyle or
situation it is that you're coming up
against understanding those and scaling
those those are great
saying that you're going to be the
person that's always going to make sure
that the client has it you're the first
person the client's going to ring you go
well if you've got a thousand clients in
whatever company it is that you you
simply cannot do that well i was the guy
that the client spoke to all along in
the first place yeah
but
the situation's changed
you're the owner or you're the guy
that's the
training manager or the sales rep
whatever
you can't do the thing that you used to
do and there's this quote again out of
uh
kyle's
uh blog post that he did
and he says in the early stages of
training an aspiring confucian gentleman
needs to memorize entire shelves of
archaic texts learn the precise angle at
which to bow and learn the lengths of
the steps with which he is to enter a
room his sitting mat must always be
perfectly straight all of this rigor and
restraint however is ultimately aimed at
producing a cultivated but nonetheless
genuine form of spontaneity indeed the
process of training is not considered
complete until the individual has passed
completely beyond the need for thought
or effort so you could talk about system
two to system one from daniel kahneman
here you could talk about uh doing and
thinking you could talk about cognition
and intuition the point is that
everything's deliberate and effortful
when you begin and after a while you're
supposed to tap into some degree of
mastery right you're supposed to spread
that out and aggregate it and widen your
view and
just see things with a little bit more
ease and grace and yet if you're totally
myopic about stuff you're not going to
be able to see that so yeah what got you
here won't get you there
next one
romantic desirability has almost no
predictive power for a long-term
relationship happiness so this is seth
stevens davidowitz
uh and his book don't trust your gut is
fantastic so he looked at the research
work of a lady called samantha joel she
teamed up with 85 of the world's most
renowned scientists combining data from
43 studies mining hundreds of variables
collected from more than 10 000 couples
and utilizing state-of-the-art machine
learning models in an effort to help
people pick better romantic partners
and these machine models
basically were completely unable to have
any predictive power over whether
couples were going to be uh happy long
term
especially
using
traditional or what would be typically
thought of as
desirable traits in a partner so
height income their job conventional
attractiveness and sexual tastes
basically all of the things that people
optimize for in online dating
it turned out that they had the lowest
correlation when predicting long-term
relationship happiness
all of the things right like you can
literally set i think it's bumble or
hinge you can set a height filter
height has
zero predictive power when it comes to
long-term relationship happiness and yet
it's one of the things that you can look
at on the front end income job these are
the sort of things that get listed on
your dating profile or you ask someone
like what's your name what do you do
it's one of the first things that comes
up conventional attractiveness again
something that's not only displayed on
online dating but also if you meet
somebody in the real world sexual tastes
you know for the most part that's going
to be something that people will
encounter before they get into a
long-term relationship with someone
none of those have any predictive power
it's basically a rounding error that
they're nothing so
you might say well
what qualities did have the most
predictive power and these were
psychological stability growth mindset
satisfaction with life conscientiousness
and a secure attachment style so
i mean no one is listing any of that
on their
dating profile and yet it's the most
important stuff when it comes to
long-term relationship happiness now
there's a caveat here which is that
you need to
one one of the pushbacks against this is
well that's all well and good but you
need the first things the height the job
the income the attractiveness the sexual
taste compatibility in order to get
yourself through the door to then be
able to take advantage perhaps of being
conscientious and having a secure
attachment style and blah blah blah
but
what it highlights is that there's
potentially a completely untapped market
of partners that are
not at first obvious as someone that you
might go out with especially people of
different racial groups
people who have unconventional jobs uh
people who have varying degrees of
income
they don't have predictive power long
term which means that for most people
sorry they don't have predictive power
long term and yet most people are
selecting them which means that if you
go for someone who doesn't have that
that is a completely untapped market
potentially full of people who are
psychologically stable with a growth
mindset and satisfaction with life and
conscientious and stuff like that so you
can optimize for an untapped market of
people who genuinely have qualities that
will ensure long-term relationship
happiness or at least contribute to it
whilst not going for the things that are
kind of all show and no grow
now another one of the problems that you
come up against here
is that
when you're online especially with the
advent of online dating this is kind of
all that people see
this is all that they're really bothered
about they're completely myopic about
these particular
um
these particular figures
but the
synopsis that they came up with in the
study was
algorithms can work out
what you'll click on but not who you'll
click with so they had unbelievable
predictive power if you put up a bunch
of different profiles they could work
out based on height and income and
attractiveness and stuff like that they
could say this with real accuracy you're
going to swipe right or swipe left on
this person and yet they were unable to
work out whether that relationship is
going to be happy long term so i think
there's just a really big lesson to take
away from that that if you are dating
and if you're looking for people
not being completely categorical with
the uh
idea that you have going into a date or
uh scouting the market for
what it is that you want in a partner i
think that's a very smart way to go
about it and here's another thing i
remember
man
going on love island one of the most
common questions that you got asked was
what's your type
and i always used to think it was kind
of a dumb question because
what they wanted you to say was
here are a very narrow band of physical
characteristics and maybe some emotional
ones uh that
sound pithy and like i like petite
blondes who've got who go to the gym and
from wigan i don't know right i don't
know what they wanted but i feel like it
was that but it always made me think it
never really resonated with me and
people that have got a really locked in
type that they go for always just
i don't know like do you really know
how well do you know yourself
do you know yourself well enough to know
the person that you don't even know if
they exist yet but to give them
some particular list of
attributes that you think would vibe
with you just how well do you know
yourself okay and now you're creating
this imaginary person that
can
be compatible with yourself i don't i
don't know that's not to say that we
can't have preferences and also not to
say that we can't learn from previous
relationships you know if you're in a
relationship with an incredibly
disagreeable person that that is not
good for you or if you're in a
relationship with somebody that works
all the time or somebody that isn't into
fitness or whatever it might be
but what's your type and having a really
sort of serious type and then if nothing
else after all of this time
uh the state-of-the-art machine learning
models looking at ten thousand couples
backs up what i say right that basically
having a type is completely pointless
unless you're talking about secure
attachment styles and stuff like that
next one this is another huban one and
this actually came out of the comments
on the episode which is
so cool this is one of the reasons that
i'm so proud of modern wisdom and
the audience that we've built because
it's super wide-ranging right when
people ask me when people ask what's
modern wisdom about it's a
60-second answer of me going well it's
interesting because there's porn stars
but there's philosophers there's
psychologists and then sometimes there's
people that are trying to maximize our
ability to do space flight and then
there's like this whole other area of
health and fitness and then i've got
these two mates from the uk and we kind
of talk about how to make the best
toasted sandwich uh so yeah the kind of
that and what they wanted to hear was oh
it's about football or something
but
i don't give them a sufficiently good
answer one of the advantages of that is
that it's created an audience which has
really really smart insights and it gets
pulled out of left field so this was
really cool so hubermann was talking
about the fact that
he
has tattoos and yet doesn't show them
and one of the reasons for that is that
you can't control the perceptions of
other people the quote was be careful
you can't control the perceptions of
other people one of the comments really
pulled this out and it was really smart
he said
this is such a wise statement despite
some people being vocal about the
subject they consider outdated like a
negative opinion of tattoos it takes
many years for a shift in the public's
eye despite us wishing it was otherwise
perhaps then it's in our own best
interests to act in accordance to how
the world is
rather than how we wish the world was or
how we think it ought to be
so good right so
like i wish that i'd said that on the
on the podcast uh
but
just great insight about the fact that
you are unable to alter the way that
your actions are going to be interpreted
now there's the stoic fork thing here
which is like you just do the thing that
you do and you can control yourself up
until the bounds of your body and then
after that it's all out into the ether
right and you're just relying on
that to kick back to you but another
thing is that you go well
how is the world at the moment
and how should i act given the way that
it is
because an idealistic view or the hope
that maybe you know maybe you know for
an absolute fact
that
life for all of humanity would be better
if this stopped or this started
but it's not not yet
and if you're doing something like
getting tattoos that you can't cover up
or like
making any serious life decision
in the hopes that society is going to
catch up to your view of how that should
be interpreted even if the way that it's
i don't think that i don't think the
tattoo should really matter that much i
don't think that it is that big of a
deal if someone's got tattoos that shows
i think we're kind of it seems like
we're past that
and yet you can't deny the fact that
there are certain areas of the world
that are like a newscaster someone
that's doing the nine o'clock news with
a neck tattoo
is is going to cause a lot of people to
think that's a bit strange that's a
little bit off that doesn't look like a
newscaster should that be the case maybe
not but you can't deny the fact that
that's the way that the world is
so you need to act
in accordance with the way that the
world is or at least get yourself close
to it right this is one of the problems
with people who are
like super
um disagreeable heterodox cynical lone
rangery types because
yeah i
respect the fact that you care more
about your approach to something or your
desire to do something in a certain way
than in the way that it's going to be
perceived and you can say well this
isn't the way that it's supposed to be
and i'm going to continue to do it until
things change
well
i get that but
the world is going to be able to stay
ignorant or stupid a lot longer than you
can stay resilient and if nothing else
you're not you're not stopping the
you're not cutting the costs
or you are you are bearing the burden
all on yourself
in the hopes of what changing the world
around you
that's the way that campaigns happened
that's the way that stuff goes on but
when it comes to things that aren't
uh
existentially important perhaps like the
decision of the way that you present at
work
maybe
uh i feel like
acting in accordance with the way that
the world is not the way that you would
have it be is probably smart
next one when you get bored with the
process you negatively change your
trajectory at shane parish so i've had
this for ages of playing around with
this quote and i couldn't really work
out what it meant to me and then
i realized that
if you start doing something which is
supposed to be a love right which is a
hobby or
a pet project or whatever and then you
turn it into a labor if you monetize it
if you commercialize it if you make it
into something
a lot of the time you can
turn that love into a labor
and kind of destroy the motivation for
it
the desire to do it really overall
i know someone that loves to knit on a
weekend right or
wants to
enjoys doing kung fu and decides to
sell their knitting or open a kung fu
studio but before long
they're now spending most of their time
doing emails back and forth with sales
or dealing with membership requests for
their kung fu studio
and they they're practicing less kung fu
now than they were when it was a hobby
that's not to say that you can't take
something that you're passionate about
or a recreation and turn it into a
business that you're going to love i
just think that you need to protect the
love bit at all costs that's the
important part the important part is the
fact that you love the thing that you do
and
maybe
maybe having an unbelievably successful
business is incompatible with the amount
of degradation of love for that pursuit
that you would have to put up with the
price that you would have to pay in
terms of how much you would now start to
hate the thing that you do
would be so high that it doesn't make
sense for you to get a business out of
it or it doesn't make sense for you to
grow a business past a particular place
like let's say that your tolerance for
doing kung fu
teaching kung fu and a little army of
kung fu teachers that work at your
studio maybe that's enough right you
could put up with that but what if you
wanted to open up one in the next town
over or four in the next city's over
okay there's going to become a point
where it's now no longer about it being
a recreation it's actually about it
being a business now you might find out
that you love business more than you
ever love doing kung fu or knitting and
if that's so then fantastic but
my point being
protect
the process that you go through
protect
the protected daily
the way that you show up to do the stuff
that you love and know that if you try
and turn the thing that you love into a
commercial opportunity
you're
you're inevitably going to change the
nature of your relationship with it it's
going to start to feel it's definitely
not going to feel less like work when
you make it into work
right you turn knitting into a job it's
not going to feel less like a job the
very best you can hope for is that you
somehow manage to fluke it out and the
business runs totally smoothly or you've
got an
auntie that's an ops director or
something and she can step in and do it
all for you brilliant but for the most
part just protect the things that you
love
uh next up the reverse role model so
this was something that i reflected on
uh
after having done some therapy with a
timeline therapist guy called vinnie
shulman and we were talking about my
past and the place that i'd grown up
which didn't have
a whole lot of people that were kind of
similar to
my mindset
and it meant that i didn't have a
massive amount of
um
admirable inspirational figures when i
was growing up
there was people that had fantastic
elements here and there and you know i
could pick parts of things that i wanted
but there was a lot
a lot of people that were
really
like the person i didn't want to be
rather than like the person i did
and
there was a chip on my shoulder for a
while because i felt
it i felt like it was unfair that i i
hadn't had the
i don't know the
um ground grooved in front of me in the
way that i should have done so i could
have just seen the path you know at
nine years old because my whatever
teacher decided that he was going to
take me under his wing or something
which is that like romantic story um but
i realized that
a lot of the time
what we're looking to do in life or you
can achieve a lot of success in life
by avoiding stupidity rather than trying
to be smart almost all of your successes
in life will come from avoiding being
stupid rather than trying to be super
super smart you can get a huge way
through existence simply by avoiding
ruin
and what you can do
is
use the people that you don't look up to
as
warning flags in the ground to direct
you away from areas that you don't want
to be
let's say that it is more important to
avoid destruction than it is to chase
success right if that's the case the
fact that you have a ton of people
around you that are pointing in the
direction of destruction is fantastic
because that's warning flag warning flag
warning flag okay i'll weave my way
through this i'm not gonna
have my relationship like this person
i'm not going to pick up a gambling
addiction like this person i'm not going
to deal with my finances like that i'm
not going to have a lack of control of
my emotions like that person or lack of
ability to express myself or whatever it
might be all of that right these are all
individual markers in the ground that
highlight to you things that you don't
want to have happen in your life
that's
pretty useful
is that more useful than a positive role
model
i don't know but i think
i think there's a an argument to be made
that it's not far off right
it's definitely definitely up there
so
if you're in a place or if you had an
upbringing where you don't feel like
you've got the
sort of role models that you want look
around and
see if there's some idiots that you can
use instead because
they're kind of just as useful
next one this is james altucher
who was on the show maybe three years
ago quite a while ago now but he had
this
he's like a weird guy
unique fella
built a ton of businesses lost all of
the money twice
uh
chess
master or grandmaster perhaps as well
also a trader also an author also a
blogger just podcast interesting dude
and he said your weirdness is your
competitive advantage and this is from
naval that no one can beat you at being
you
so if you have a unique
collection of idiosyncrasies and
background and the way that you talk and
your past traumas and your life
experiences and all of that stuff that's
what sets you apart as far as i can see
and james put it forward as well that
the weirder you are the more unique you
are which means the more competitive and
interesting you are because it if you
fully inhabit all of the things that
you've got there is no one else that has
your collection of life experiences and
upbringing and genes and all of that
right no one literally so by design the
best way to be competitive is to try and
funnel
everything that you are in as much of an
unencumbered way as frictionlessly as
possible
that's
the best way that i can see to do it and
seems to work for james
brian greene the moment to moment of
almost anything you're doing is a grind
it is only upon completion in reflection
where you can see the glory
brian green is a physicist and that
sounds like
i don't know some basketball coach or
like some david goggins [ __ ]
uh the moment to moment of almost
anything you are doing is a grind it is
only upon completion in reflection where
you can see the glory this is just cool
right coming from a guy who writes a lot
of papers and does a lot of books has
been involved in academia and
he's done the grind he's done the graft
right you can see this guy you can
imagine him sitting at his desk late at
night
you know he's texted the missus saying
that he's not going to be home and she's
put the kids to bed and she's already
asleep and he's still working away over
his desk this big mahogany wood thing
and he's still slaving away over papers
or writing a book or doing whatever
and
i think that there is a view
because of how romanticized motivation
is and also because of how we see
[ __ ] think about how we see the main
section of someone's development in a
movie
it's a montage you know you here's the
ufc
movie about the kid that gets bullied in
school and then he's bullied in school
and he gets bullied one too many times
so he joins the uf
mma gym and then in the mma gym there's
the call to adventure and then he tries
to quit and then he decides he's going
to go and he goes back and that period
in between knows sweet [ __ ] all about
mma to complete beast and able to take
down the high school college bully or
whatever
right that that is usually at most
a 20-minute
monologue compilation with some
interactions with his family saying
you're working too hard and you
shouldn't do this and blah blah blah
that
that gives an unbelievably romanticized
view of the moment to moment of anything
that you're doing of working hard of
doing stuff
and yet
in reflection what we want to be able to
see is that the whole
the whole journey
the experience of it and the reflection
of it was beautiful but you you don't
get that it's only in reflection that
when you look back at all of the hard
times and the late nights and the
ordering the domino's pizza with the
team at two in the morning and cracking
it out because you needed to get it done
for 9am and we submitted the
presentation with five minutes to spare
and we nailed it and we got the client
and stuff
that's
that's cool in retrospect you can't make
the 3 a.m finish and the all-nighter
suck any less the suck is just suck
right that's it
and
realizing that especially pairing this
with leaning into discomfort training
for the difficult
with using discipline not motivation
i really think i wonder why this been
i'm not sure why i've had so much stuff
today that's about discipline and
motivation
and things i'm not feeling particularly
unmotivated or undisciplined at the
moment but it's definitely
definitely a theme throughout these but
i think when you combine this together
look like
your normal actions
the day-to-day
reality of the stuff that you're doing
is just gonna be a bit [ __ ] for most
stuff
and maybe you can make it a bit less
[ __ ] but if it's really hard
if it's really worthwhile and if it's
something that you really want to
achieve
most of the other people would have
already achieved it or you would have a
ton of competition if it was easy
because the easiness would encourage
more and more people to go in the
barrier to entry is the difficulty the
fact that it's not a movie means that
there isn't a montage that's going to
get this done in 20 minutes time it's
going to take a long consistent
effortful journey for you to get from
where you are to where you want to be
and then in reflection you get to see
the glory but in reflection you
shouldn't feel like oh looking back this
was really good therefore when the next
thing starts i should see all of the
elements of difficulty as an aberration
this is something that shouldn't be it's
like no this is what it is this is how
it is
in reflection it's going to be good but
at the moment it's going to suck
next one
accept that all of your heroes are full
of [ __ ] your heroes aren't gods they're
just regular people who probably got
good at one thing by neglecting
literally everything else so this was
jason parkin who wrote an awesome blog
post malice disagrees with me vehemently
on this
he's adamant that heroes are or a lot of
the super successful people are able to
do multiple things i disagree a little
bit more i think that you can get
yourself to maybe
90 or 95 the 90th or 95th percentile of
a particular pursuit whilst doing other
stuff but as you start to ascend toward
the real
top
of anything which is typically where
heroes are
it's just you're going to be out out
competed by somebody that decides to not
try
and do
knitting whilst running a kung fu studio
right the best kung fu studio guy is
going to live and breathe kung fu studio
stuff
the best knitting person who's going to
live and breathe knitting stuff so when
you try to start combining other stuff
you realize
i i feel like it is more likely to be a
disadvantage unless it's somehow
synergistic and it's able to help you
along the way but i don't think that it
does and the point here is that
all of the people that we admire have
made huge sacrifices they've got rid of
pretty much everything else in order to
get to the place that they that they're
at now and then you look up at them as
as this unbelievably worthy of
admiration human who they very well
might be
but it's that tiger wood story thing
again about the the price that you have
to pay to be the person you admire is a
price that you probably wouldn't want to
put your hand in the pocket for it's so
monotonous
and boring
and
simple
that it just doesn't display itself it's
not the reality of how you
the reality of what you see your heroes
doing and what you imagine them doing
and
what they're genuinely doing is is
worlds apart uh your heroes aren't gods
they're just regular people who probably
got good at one thing by neglecting
literally everything else family diet
rest social life
health perhaps you know some of the best
business guys on the planet i i don't
want their blood pressure
okay so
is the price of the blood pressure worth
the price of the successful company well
that's that's what you need to do but
it's a reminder except all of your
heroes are full of [ __ ] like
they're just normal people
that committed themselves unbelievably
hard to one or a couple of things that
somehow synergistically work
um should i do one more let's do one
more i'll do one more
the expectation effect so this is
one of the best books that i've read
this year from david robson and in it he
just explains about how
the actions that we have impact our
daily existence way more than we think
and the thoughts that we have
can impact the way that our bodies
operate there's this uh example that
uses about gluten where people got
brought into a lab and people who hadn't
eaten gluten because they expected that
they had done they'd been told that the
meal contained gluten but it didn't they
started breaking out in hives and having
diarrhea and having inflammation and
headaches and all this sort of stuff
well what's going on there that they
didn't eat any gluten and they might not
have been biologically intolerant to
gluten well it's because they expected
it and they're able to manifest this
sort of stuff the same thing goes for a
study that was done on vo2 max tests
about how effective people were at
blowing up co2 there were people that
had genetic mutations that meant that
their lungs were more efficient but they
were told that they didn't have it and
that they would probably perform poorly
the people who didn't have the mutation
but were told that they did outperform
the people who did have the mutation but
were told that they didn't which means
that your expectations are literally
more powerful than your genes when it
comes to this same thing goes for
longevity for people's recovery from
chronic illness and stuff like that
their expectations are so powerful and
it's
because i hate the secret so much and
rhonda byrne is
an awful human
i really do it's so close to that sort
of woo
sending out good vibes and and david
thankfully addresses it in the book and
he's like look i i don't agree with that
stuff either and i'm not a fan of it
which made me like him even more
but
there is something to be said for taking
as much of an agentic
like high agency high sovereignty i have
control over this and my destiny
approach is possible and it kind of
explains why optimists tend to live
longer like if you're optimistic you're
just going to see yourself as being more
capable to get over stuff but again like
we said before no matter what the
challenges are that you've come up
against like everything's fine
you're listening to this podcast right
all of the issues and the difficulties
that you've had
you've managed to get past so why not
expect that you're going to be able to
get past this thing again
and
yeah that expectation effect is is
fantastic the episode is amazing and um
you should go and check it out it's a
fantastic insight it's very empowering
as well like it genuinely does help to
make you believe look i have control
over the things that i even don't think
that i necessarily have control over
like
health outcomes
when being diagnosed with something or
like my ability to change how efficient
i am at blowing off co2 even if i don't
have the right genetic
marker for it or something
but look i'm going to leave it there uh
i appreciate you all thank you joco
episode comes out this week
400k q a will come out soon it may have
left that a little bit late we might be
a bit closer to 450 by the time that
comes out uh but i love you all uh
that's it
peace
what's happening people thank you very
much for tuning in if you enjoyed that
episode then press here for a selection
of the best clips from the podcast over
the last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
you